also das ist das zukunftsteam von armin
laschet dass er da gerade teilweise
recht stolz vorgestellt hat in der
cdu-zentrale dem konrad-adenauer-haus da
lohnt sich noch mal darüber zu sprechen
vor allen dingen über den ein oder
anderen neuen namen das tun wir hiermit
bildpolitik chef jan schäfer aber
erstmal die entscheidende frage auch
hier hinter uns rettet jetzt diese
truppe diesen doch ziemlich
heruntergekommenen laschet wahlkampf
kann das ist die entscheidende frage ich
benutze man eine analogie aus dem
fußball habe den eindruck wir sind jetzt
in der 80 minute in einem spiel noch
drei wochen bis zur entscheidenden wahl
und die frage ist armin laschet licht 0
zu 3 hinten kann das team wasser gerade
forscht gestellt hat diese
einwechslungen die ihr jetzt vornimmt
reicht das aus um aus dem 0 zu 3 1
mindestens 32 er eigentlich 1 4 zu 3 zu
machen wir sind drei stürmer ganz klar
aufgefallen ich glaube die könnten es
noch drehen also quasi eine troika für
lasche die wir jetzt hier auch natürlich
friedrich merz ganz klar
nicht gerade der totale zukunfts name
oder also der ein neuer arbeit voll
kompetenz steht für steht für
wirtschaftskompetenz er steht für
finanzkompetenz so wurde er auch
vorgestellt so hat er sich ja auch ein
gebracht also wenn christian lindner ein
anrecht auf dieses finanzministerium
meint zu haben dann glaube ich hat ihm
das friedrich merz heute wieder ein
bisschen stunde jetzt ist ja auch etwas
wichtig da unterbrechen als armin
laschet braucht werden eine umfrage
gemacht habe ich einmal daran erinnern
dies noch ein paar wochen her und da
haben eine ein große mehrheit der
menschen haben gesagt also kompetenz
sehen wir eher im letzten drittel von
zehn plätzen bei armin laschet also auf
einmal brauche auch jemanden der ihn in
sachen kompetenz noch meinen rücken
stärkt weil offenbar die wählerinnen und
wähler laut unserer umfrage das gefühl
haben um da könnte er noch ein monat es
ist ein ko dass er ihn jetzt der jetzt
nicht immer als totaler laschet weniger
hat um es vorsichtig zu sagen jetzt sind
sein team geholt das ist natürlich aber
kein frischer name jan fischer nahm aber
sind prominenter name also von denen
acht personen die insgesamt in diesem
team sind ist friedrich merz natürlich
der prominenteste name und von daher
auch ein entscheidendes zugpferd der
zweite name der sicherlich dazu
beitragen wird dass armin laschet jetzt
nochmal ordentlich aufholen kann das ist
peter neumann der terrorismusexperte wir
uns gerade bei bild natürlich schon seit
jahren bekannt aufgrund seiner sehr
fundierten 1 diesen ein absoluter kenner
vom king's college in london der ja auch
sehr deutlich gesagt hat warum er
eigentlich jetzt für armin laschet
antritt das waren eigentlich glaube ich
die besten aussagen die er getroffen hat
er war derjenige der am stärksten
eingegangen ist auf das thema was er
natürlich betreut aber auch gesagt hat
warum armin laschet jetzt unterstützt
und warum er das thema für wichtig hält
und um die troika komplett zu machen
giorgio ist natürlich so was wie ein 1 1
superstar auch in diesem in diesem trio
weil er der der saga unbekannteste
erfrischendsten und in dem sinne
natürlich auch der kreativste und der
leute zugehen nachdem anja der
rauchpausen wieder gerade bei seinem auf
er steht für etwas was der union bisher
komplett fehlt auch die anderen
kandidaten die jetzt vorgestellt wurden
für das team sind ja eigentlich treue
parteiseele muss man sagen aber er ist
ein quereinsteiger das was friedrich
merz in gewisser weise auch sehr sein
comeback die alos ein richtiger
quereinsteiger der erstmals überhaupt in
den bundestag möchte und auch mit dem
was er gesagt hat eigentlich sehr
deutlich gemacht hat dass er andere
potenziale noch in der cdu noch in der
csu sieht als sie bisher da sind ich
glaube da besteht jetzt für armin
laschet die chance mit diesem mit dieser
troika
wählerstimmen an sich zu binden die
möglicherweise bisher die union nicht
gewählt haben aber die frage ist zehn
minuten vor ende der partie langen diese
drei aus und sind wirklich die drei über
die anderen können wir eine ansprechende
sind wirklich die 3 die jetzt für armin
laschet wie heißt es so schön die kohle
aus dem feuer holen müssen
[Musik]